I don't understand the whole hype with
this it does make me want to wear Uggs
though all my white girlfriends and all
my bottom gay friends like this I don't
like to do seasonal things because then
when it's gone it's like a breakup I
think that there's a man like pumpkin in
it no [ __ ] way there's pumpkin to
this and I ha first thing I didn't know
they were hot dude have you looked
inside oh there's oil at the top where
did the local come from
do you think it smells like weed it
smells like we yeah maybe that's why
everyone likes it
cheers Cheers oh man oh I like that
actually I want it like by a fire and
like a bearskin rug I want to want to
Gilmore Girls cuz this is making me so
basic hi to me this is what pumpkin
tastes like I don't taste pumpkin
doesn't taste it all like real pumpkins
I think you'd have to tell me that this
is pumpkin I'm in seventh grade and this
is bath and Bodyworks I just drank it it
smells good this is the perfect just
coffee we just go yeah yeah exactly and
hocus-pocus is on a Disney yeah it's
like pumpkin pie chewed up like spat
into like a coffee machine could you
have this every day
no I feel like a I feel like a lard ass
it's just like a new way to like get
people excited about something that they
probably if it was available all year
wouldn't be that exciting but I kind of
can't stop drinking it like I'm like I
am in a defib I'll have another fifth
gotta be honest I might get this I'm
basic AF I think there's better ways to
get into the festive fall spirit go
carve a pumpkin jump in a pile of leaves
cuddle up and don't get pregnant